اعزائي المشاهدين نستكمل هذه التغطيه
للاحداث المتواتره التي تاتينا من اسطنبول
وتحديدا من ساحه تقسيم حيث وقع منذ قليل
انفجار في هذه المنطقه ادى الى سقوط عدد
من الجرحى فيما اكد محافظ اسطنبول سقوط
قتلى في هذا الانفجار
الشرطه نفذت انتشارا امنيا سريعا في
المنطقه وعمدت الى اخلاءها فورا تحسبا
لوقوع انفجار اخر
وسائل اعلام تركيا ذكرت ايضا ان الانفجار
وقع في شارع مزدحم بمنطقه تقسيم ما خلف
عددا من الاصابات في ملاده اخرون
بالفرار كما نشاهد هذه المشاهد في هذا
الشارع المزدحم من منطقه همم
شارع همم بالطبع يعني يغص بالمره بالسياح
كان المنطقه سياحيه بامتياز كنا شاهدنا
منذ قليل سيارات الاسعاف وحتى ناقلات جن
جن همم مباشره الى منطقه همم الانفجار عدد
الضحايا همم لا نعرف يعني الحديث الان عن
جرح همم ولكن محافظه اسطنبول اكد وقوع هذا
العدد ولكن حتى الساعه المعلومات الرسميه
تتحدث عن احد عشر جريحا لا نعرف مستوى
الاصابات يعني ان نتحدث عن اصابات طفيفه
همم اما عن اصابات متوسط لان بالغه مع
العلم ان محافظ اسطنبول تحدث عن وجود قتلى
همم بين همم المصابين نتيجه هذا الانفجار
السلطات اعزائي المشاهدين تتخوف من وقوع
انفجار اخر لا نعرف حتى الساعه طبيعه هذا
هذه الانفجارات او الانفجار هل هو هجوم
ارهاب هل هو سياره مفخفه هو تفجير همم
حادث عربي حتى الساعه لا نعرف تحديدا
طبيعه هذا الانفجار سنحاول همم واياكم
تساقط المعلومات تحديدا مع مراسل العربيه
زيدان زينجل هو معي الان مباشره همم
مراسلنا همم في اسطنبول زيدان اهلا وسهلا
بك همم هل همم اخر المعلومات المتوفره
لديك حول هذا الانفجار حول ملابساته عدد
الضحايا وماذا تقول السلطات حتى الساعه
نعم سابدا بالمعلومات الرسميه التي تحدث
عنها ااا والي اسطنبول على الريقايه في
تغريده قبل دقائق فقط اكد وقوع قتلى وجرحى
بسبب الانفجار الذي وقع في شارع الاستقلال
وسط تقسيم او شارع الاستقلال عفوا الوسط
اسطنبول لم يذكر والد اسطنبول ملابسات
الانفجار واسرار الانفجار لكن المعلومات
غير الرسميه وسائل الاعلام تركيا تتحدث عن
الانفجار قنبله او شيء يشبه القنبله همم
الانفجار في شارع الاستقلال صنع صدع
الانفجار او صوت الانفجار في احياء مجاوره
من شارع الاستقلال
المجاور لشارع الاستقلال ااا طبعا
بغض النظر عن حجم الانفجار لكن اتحدث هنا
عن همم وقوع انفجار في اكثر مكان مزدحم
تقريبا في اسطنبول او الدخل للمجاهدين
يعني في شارع الاستقلال بس هل من معلومات
ما الذي استهدفه تحديدا يعني محل تجاريه
مكان معين مركز معين ام لا حتى الساعه الى
وجود مثل هكذا معلومات مفصله
لا لا يوجد معلومات
الانفجار او همم المكان الذي استهدف او
المكان الذي وقع صربه التفجير لكن همم
الى اضرار في بعض المحالي اضافه طبعا الى
الجرحى والقتلى كما اكدال اسطنبول هناك
اضرار في بعض المحل التجاريه القريبه من
مكان الانفجار طبعا الشرطه التركيه اخلت
المنطقه بالكامل لتسهيل نصوص السيارات
الاسعاف اثناء الجرحى وايضا تحسبا من وقوع
او ان يكون هناك قنابل اخرى في حال كان
هناك
همم ان التسجيل كان ناجم عن قنبله حتى
الان لا توجد انباء من قبل وسائل الاعلام
التركيه الكبرى عن وجود انتحار لكن نتحدث
عن انفجار همم قنبله او تشتهر وسائل
الاعلام التركيه بوجودكم ولكن كما ذكر همم
في شارع الاستقلال وهذا اليوم يوم الاحد
يوم عطله عطله نهايه الاسبوع وايضا بدايه
عطله المدارس همم الشارع مزدحم جدا اي
انفجار من اي نوع من مهما كان حجم هذا
انفجار سيؤدي الى وقوع همم جرحى وقتلى
وهذا شيء طبعا ما ردوا اوصابه الى
الازدحام الشديد في هذه المنطقه وهو طبعا
يعني لا يوجد منطقه فعلا اليوم مزدحمه
اكثر من شارع الاستقلال في اسطنبول وهذا
ما تظهره الصور ايضا يعني يغص بالمره
بالسياح وهي بتعرف منطقه سياحيه بامتياز
همم انت اقرب الى الحدث منا هنا زيدان طيب
حددت الانفجار الانفجار كبير وعنيف همم
متوسط ام لا حتى الساعه لا يمكن الحكم
ايضا
نعم يعني بحسب المشاهد التي ااه انا شاهدت
بعض الصور الفوتوغرافيه صور على بعض وسائل
الاعلام التركيه لم اشاهد الفيديو صراحه
الذي تعرضه الان تعرضون او على الطموح قبل
قليل على الشاشه لكن الصور التي شاهدتها
يعني ربما هو انفجار متوسط وليس وليس
انفجار كبير يعني لم يكن هناك انهيار او
تدمير واجهات بالكامل لكن كما ذكرت يعني
مهما كانت حجه الانفجار في مكان مزدحم ب
10,000 همم
الزوار سيؤدي الى وقوع همم عدد من
الجرحى وايضا القتلى كما اكدال اسطنبول
والتنوين هذه هذا الانفجار في شارع
الاستقلال ليس الاول همم حدث انفجار قبل
حوالي ست سنوات في شهر مارس ايضا في شارع
الاستقلال واستهدف مجموعه سياحيه ايضا الى
بعض همم الضحايا لاعب الكره بالضبط همم
المعلومه لكن كان هناك ضحايا همم من
مجموعه سياحيه كانت تزود على الاستقلال
لكن نتحدث
ايجار وصف هذا الزحام هناك كان في شارع
الاستقلال وميدان تقسيم المجاور لشارع
الاستقلال في مقتل شارع الاستقلالنا الجهه
الشماليه هناك انتشار امني كبير وانتشار
يا الشرطه لا سيما بعد المحاوله انقلابيه
في عام 2016
[موسيقى]
وبالتالي هذا يفسر الانتشار الكثيف لقوات
الشرطه والامن
والتحذير من انفجار ثاني وهنا خطوره ال-
همم المساله
نعم بالضبط لذلك اخذت الشرطه على الثور
المنطقه بالكامل لعده اهداف او لعده اسباب
منها وصول سيارات الاسعاف بشكل سريع وايضا
اا الخشيه من
وجود قنبله اخرى او حدوث انفجار اخر همم
كما اا تحدثتم نعم انا اتابع الان اخبار
او حتى بيان والاسطنبول كما ذكرت كما ذكر
الوالي هناك قتلى وجرحى همم اليوم همم
هناك همم او حدث الانفجارات همم في تركيا
و تحديدا في اسطنبول مضى وقت طويل يعني
تقريبا حوالي ست سنوات او سبع سنوات اخر
انفجار في اسطنبول كما تعلمون ما بين عامي
2015 حتى بدايه عام 2016
كان هناك عدد من الانفجارات من ضمنها في
شارع الاستقلال جاء الجهات المنتزه كانت
همم تنظيم داعش وحجم العمل
في هذه في هذه التفجيرات المتهم الاول من
قبل السلطه
الخس بالعمال الكردستاني لذلك بعد
قليل فما
تفسيرات او همم مصادر غير رسميه ستتحدث او
همم تلقي بالمسؤوليه او همم
الاتهام على حسب العمال الفرد الاسلامي
كون الحزب او عناصر الحزب
نفذوا عده عملي
قوات الامن او ترجح ان يكون هنالك انفجار
ثاني هذا يؤكد بما لا يقبل الشك انه كان
لدى الاستخبارات التركيه معلومات يعني لما
تتوقع انفجار ثاني انه في معلومات بان
هنالك او امكانيه كبيره لانفجار ثاني وهذا
ما يحبب يعني او همم يشير الى فرضيه العمل
الارهابي اكثر منه الحدث العربي
نعم بالتاكيد لا شك ان اليوم ال ااه مخاوف
الامنيه من وجود انفجار سهل طبعا طبيعه
انفجار لا يمكن ان نتحدث مثلا عن انفجار
همم بانبوب غاز باحد المحاكم الانفجار وقع
خارج او في وسط شارع الاستقلال لذلك موضوع
فرضيه الانفجار الطبيعي او حادث عربي حتى
الان غير موجوده لان الصور الاوليه تتحدى
او تشير الى وجود انفجار في وسط شارع
الاستقلال بالتالي طبعا المخاوف الامنيه
همم مرتفعه وترجح ان هذا العمل هو عمل
ارهابي او نتيجه عمل ارهابي لذلك هناك
مخاوف من ان في حال كان هذا العمل هل هناك
همم مرحله اخرى من هذا الاعمال او ان هذا
الانفجار او لعمليه توقفت هنا لذلك طيب ان
هذا الموضوع همم
من السلطات التركيه حول همم همم شكرا
جزيلا لك زيدان سنعود اليك في سياق هذه
النشره فور اي جديد على كل المزيد من
المتابعه ايضا والتحليل في خلفيات هذا
الهجوم او هذا الانفجار ينضم اليه من
اسطنبول الان المحلل السياسي سمير صالح
سمير اهلا وسهلا بك اولا اريد منك اي
قراءه يمكن اعطائها لهذا الانفجار وهل همم
يعني تحبث فرضيه العمل الارهابي يعني انه
كل المؤشرات تقول انه عمل ارهابي واذا كان
كذلك اي اشارات واي رسائل يحملها هذا
الانفجار ولما
صحيح داني وحي الجميع اولا يعني طبعا نحن
ممتلئه الان للوسائل الاعلام التركيه
مختلف الوسائل الاعلام وما تنقله حتى
الساعه لا يجعلنا كما اشارتهم ايضا قبل
قليل الكثير من المعلومات الرسميه الموثقه
باستثناء تغريدات
محافظه اسطنبول الذي اشار انه في قتلنا
وجرحه كما فهمنا من تغريداتهم كما انتم
ذكرتم
الانفجار طبعا في اكثر من روايه الان يتم
تنقلها انه وقع في منتصف همم
اوغلو التي هي جزء من منطقه تقسيم ككل همم
طبعا النقطه الاساسيه كل الاحتمالات ما
زالتنا يعني احتمال طبعا ان يكون حادث
عربي ان يكون ايضا عمل همم ارهابي تم بهذا
الشكل لكن الان في اكثر من معلومه تقول
انه همم هذه المنطقه فيها كثافه امنيه
كبيره
لانوس رجال الامن يتجولون في هذه الجاده
التي تعتبر كما تعرف انت ايضا
منفذ التجاري وسياحي بالنسبه لمدينه
اسطنبول
لنسلم جدلا يعني بتعرف لا نريد ان نرجم
بالغيب ولكن فرضيه العمل الارهاب اذا كان
عملا ارهابيا اولا اي جهات قد تكون وراءه
ومن ثم اي رسائل يبعثها الى السلطات
التركيه ولماذا في هذا التوقيت
صحيح اذا عدنا قريبا الى الارشيف انا وانت
واتبعنا لعمليات ارهابيه من هذا النوع
وقعت في اسطنبول نرى انه في اصابع موجهه
باستمرار نحو مجموعات حزب العمال او
مجموعات محسوبه على الجماعات الارهابيه
المتطرفه داعش وغيرها من هذه المجموعات
التركيز بدرجه اساسيه في السنوات
الجناحين في السابق ربما كان في مجموعات
ايضا محسوبه على اليسار اليسار المتشدد في
متطرف في تركيا لكن ايضا اعمل هذه
المجموعات انتهت تقريبا في المدن التركيه
كان في عمليات امنيه واسعه ضد تصفيه هذه
المجموعات اكثر اليسار المتشدد المتطرف في
تركيا الان بالع
وده ايضا قام بعمليه
في اسطنبول طبعا لذلك
الاحتمالات ايضا ممنوعه بهذا الاتجاه يمكن
الان حتى الان
تحتار بمرحله انه
البحث انت عمليه انتحاريه تمت انه كانت
مثلا يحبها مشاهده في حقيبه
وانفجرت اكثر من سيناريو الان اذا كان عمل
همم
ارهابي انتحاري فهذا سيذهب بوراء
سيناريوات التي تحدثت انا عنها قبل قليل
يعني مجموعات عناصر حزب العمال هو مش معاد
همم ارهابيه محسوبه على تنظيم داعش وفولهم
العناصر التابعه له همم
الاخيره اظن علينا التميز قليل بعد دقائق
ربما قد توضح الصوره اكثر فاكثر حوله ما
الذي جرى لي لكن
هو نحن لا نتمنى ان ضريح حتى الساعه
الصغير حاول تساقط يعني المعلومات خصوصا
ما ذكروا مده عام اسطنبول همم منذ قليل
انه فتح تحقيق في الانفجار ورجح ان يكون
الانفجار عمليه ارهابيه يعني ترجيح المده
العام في اسطنبول ان يكون عمليه ارهابيه
هذا يفتح شهيه التساؤلات يعني انه همم الى
من الرسائل موجهه يعني مواجهه الى من يعني
الى الحكومه التركيه همم الى الحسبه همم
رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وشو الاهداف في هذا
التوقيت لانه احنا عم نقول يوم الاحد
صحيح اذا ما ذهبنا وراء سيناري وانه في
عمل غير هذه التام من قبل هذه المجموعات
التي نتحدث عنها انا عنها قبل قليل
فبالشق الاول الموضوع مجموعات حزب العماني
ارهابي مرتبطه بالعمليات الامنيه العسكريه
الواسعه التي تتم من قبل الاجهزه العسكريه
الامنيه التركيه ضد هذه العناصر سواء كان
في شمال العراق او في شمال سوريا
انه ايضا عناصر من هذه المجموعه الارهابيه
تسلم نفسها بدات تسلم نفسها بشكل متزايد
في الاونه الاخيره وهذا يعني انه هذه
المجموعات الان تعاني من مشكله اكبر
بيتزاهات نحو
الانتهاء هذه فرضيه اولى فرديه ثانيه اذا
كانت مرتبطه هذه العمليه في مجموعات داعش
الارهابي همم وعناصرهم هذه ايضا مرتبطه
بالعمليات العسكريه
والتدابير الجديده اللي تم اتخاذها كما
ستذكر في منطقه ادلب وجوارها والموقف
التركي الحازم ضد هذه المجموعات بعد ما
حاول القيام بعمليه قدم وانتشار والتمدد
في شمال الغرب سوريا في الشهر الاخير لذلك
طبعا هذا الشيء
مرتبط بانه هل هناك عمليه ارهابي ام لا
لكن طبعا كما قلت لك حتى الان طالما انه
لا يوجد شيء رسمي من المباراه المعلومات
نعم في قتل ربما كما يقال وجرحى في هذه
المنطقه هذا هو حاكم اسطنبول هو حاكم
اسطنبول تحدث يعني اكد وجود قتله ولكن لا
نعرف عدد عدد هؤلاء حتى الجرح لا نعرف
يعني مستواه يعني انه جراح متبسطه جراحه
بليغه جراحه طفيه فلا نعرف ولكن يعني اعمل
حاول فقط انه نطل على المشهد همم استاذ
سمير معك ومع الضيوف لانه همم المنطقه
التي جرى فيها هذا الانفجار خصوصا اذا
يعني تعزز همم تعززت فرضيه العمل الارهابي
في هذه الرسائل في اكثر من همم اتجاه
استاذ سمير ابقى معي سعودي اليك بعد قليل
لناخذ همم من همم الكاتب الصحفي في راس
رضوان ابن وهو مع من اسطنبول هو الاستاذ
فراس اريد تعليق همم ملك مباشره على هذا
الانفجار كيف تقرا هذا الانفجار ما هي
دلالاته
من حيث اولا جغرافيه مكانا الانفجار من
حيث التوقيت واي جهه قد تكون وراءه في حال
تعززت فرضيه العمل الارهابي كما تشير
المعلومات حتى الساعه والتي لا نتبنى اي
فرضيه في قناه العربيه نحن فقط نحاول تسقط
المعلومات
ممكن نقول انا اسكن بالقرب من تلك المنطقه
السابق الذي حصل عند الملعب
هذه المره لم نسمع اي صوت ولذلك الانفجار
كقيلا انه محدود صغير تلك المنطقه اييه
يعني معروف انها محصله امنيا ولكن انا
اسمع حتى اصوات السيارات الاسعاف والاطفاء
والى اخره
ولذلك يعني اول ما ممكن اقول لك في بعد
هذا الانفجار هناك صدمه عند الجميع اا
يعني قبل مساله الخوف او الهلع من المساج
انفجار الكل مصدوم يعني لم يفهم ما حصل
خصوصا ان احنا نتكلم عن سنوات ناجحه
الداخليه التركيه قبل ست سنوات ومنها كثير
من العمليات ولم يحصل اي شيء لكن الان نحن
نتكلم عن منطقه همم يعني معروفه يعني
كثافتها سياحيه حتى سكان المنطقه يذهبون
اليها ونحن في يوم الاحد عطله ونحن فيه جو
جميلته همم
يعني رساله صادمه قويه جدا
لذلك انا بس بس اريد يعني ان يعني اشير
الى بعض المعلومات
بالطبع نحن لدينا صور في قناه العربيه
لمشاهد قتلى ولكن تعب لحساسيه همم هذه
المشاهد لا نعرضها يعني ما قاله همم حاكم
اسطنبول بوجود قتلى نستطيع تاكيده كما
لانه في مشاهد بوجود قتله ولكن تعلم نحن
لا نعرض هذه الصور تعرف يعني في كود اوف
اكس يعني اخلاقيات المهنه لا تفرض علينا
وهذا يؤكد انه الانفجار ليس الانفجار
بسيطا او محدودا او انفجار عربي خصوصا همم
لما نشاهد حجم الانتشار الامني
الكثيف ال- ال- سيارات الاسعاف التي هرعت
الى المكان
والتحذير من انفجار ثاني فهذا يحبز فرضيه
العامه الارهابي مع ذلك نحن لا نتمنى اي
همم فرضيه فقط نحاول تحليل المشهد همم معك
تفضل استاذ فراس
نعم وانا حتى اميل الى مساله عمل ارهابي
لان حصل قبل فتره انفجار غاز هناك كانت
تسرب الغاز ولكن اتضح مباشره
لكن هذه المره ليست في منطقه لنقل انها
فيها انفجار غاز والله هي في منتصف الطريق
الصور ايضا نقطه ثانيه هل هناك يعني حزام
ناسف شخص فجر نفسه حتى هذه اللحظه ليس
مقترح الامر همم وهذه النقطه قبل هذه
السنوات حصل نفس التفجير في قليل جدا من
هذه المنطقه وكانت داعش خلف هذا التغيير
لكن هذه المره هل هي داعش ام حزب العمال
الكردستاني اظن هذا يعني يحتاج الى
التحقيقات من قبل ذلك ال همم الداخليه
بشكل همم مكسر في هذا السياق الاجراءات
هذه التي تكلمت عنها هي ربما ستكون
تركيا
كل السيارات
البوليس الان والشرطه موجوده بشكل كبير
جدا لكن عندما نحن نتكلم على منطقه
التقسيم هي يعني قلب العاصمه المتوزعه على
المناطق السياحيه وهو ما حولها يعني ان
اظن ان الرساله واضحه نحن على ابواب
انتخابات ايضا هل هذه رساله تضر
بتلاف الحاكم قبل الشهود للانتخابات لان
بدات همم الاختلاف الحاكم بدا بالمخاطبات
السياسيه والسفر الى الولايات الاخرى من
اجل التحضير للانتخابات
في شكل يعني دقيق جدا وحتى كيف تسربت هذه
العمليه يعني احنا حتى الان نتكلم في
نظريه العمليه الى ان تصرف ذلك
يحتاج الى همم يعني قراءه من قبل الوظائف
الامن الداخليه كيف حصل هذا التسرب
ثلاث منطقه يعني محصنه امنيه بامتياز يعني
حتى السواحل بيروحوا اللاهونيك يعني
المنطقه التقسيم وهذه الشارع دائما في
وجود امن كثيف همم منعا لحدوث اي حوادث
حتى بسيطه فكيف بحجم بانفجار بهذا الحجم
دعني اعود الى السيد سمير صالح استاذ سمير
بس اريد همم تعليق منك الاستاذ في راس عم
بيقول التفجير في الزمان والمكان مدروس
جدا لاعطاء اكثر من رساله خصوصا ونحن على
اعتاب انتخابات همم في تركيا تحديدا رساله
الى ائتلاف الحزب الحاكم ما رايك بهذا
الكلام
اذا كان طبعا السيناريو يقول
الحدوث وجود عمل ارهابي
حول ما جرى طبعا اكثر من احتمال خصوصا انه
مساله ضربته بالتطورات السياسيه داخل
التركي فاظن انه هذه المساله نعم يعني من
الممكن ان تناقش في اطار لان سياسي امني
انتخابي في اكثر من بلد سيتم بحثه لكن انا
اظن انه ال- ال- المبكر القول انه هذه
المساله ربطها مباشره
بالانتخابات في تركيا بعد ثمانيه اشهر اظن
المساله مرتبطه اكثر كما قلت لها قبل قليل
في موضوع مجرى فيه همم ما يجري في شمال
العراق عمليات ضدها المجموعات الارهابيه
او في شمال سوريا هو الاقرب ااا الى
الواقع في هذه المرحله طيب شكرا استاذ
سمير صالح المحلل السياسي من اسطنبول عود
الى السيد فراس رضوان اوغلو هو معي ايضا
من اسطنبول
استاذ فراس همم لو سلمنا جدلا انه تاكدت
يعني فرضيه العمل الارهابي هنا السؤال اي
رد فعل من قبل السلطات التركيه وبتعرف مثل
السيد سمير صالحه هنالك يعني احتمالات
يعني احتمال ان يكون داعش وراء همم هذه
العمليه او حزب العمال الكردستاني طيب في
حال كان داعش اي رد من قبل السلطات
التركيه وفي حال كان حزب العمال اي رد
ايضا من قبل السلطات التركيه ونحن في اطار
الافتراضات والفرضيات وعيد فاذكر
مسلسل سمير في في هذه الفرديه متعلقه بشكل
كبير في مسلسل ما يحصل في الشمال السوري
وفي شمال العراق ربما ايضا نفس الشيء ااا
ماذا ستفعل
الداخليات كثيره لكن اول شيء هذا راي
الشخصي عليها ان تبحث عن الخلل الذي اوص
على الى هذه العمليه لان الامور الاخرى
اظن لديها القدره هي تعلم تماما يعني هناك
يعني توزع للاعمال بين المخابرات العسكريه
الامن الشرطه ولذلك يعني اعاده تنسيق لهذا
العمل لكن هل همم البحث عن الخلل هو بدايه
الامر انا اظن ذلك حتى تتجنب يعني
تخوف في الحصول عمليات اخرى في مناطق اخرى
هذا مهم لان قبل همم هناك همم عمليه الحزب
العمال الكردستاني في مدينه اخرى في تركيا
قبل همم يعني
عده ايام وهمم تم احباط طبعا
اكتبها مقتل شرطي في في تركيا اذا يعني
هذا الذي يجعل اننا نحن نفكر بين الامير
اكثر يلا نحن من عمان كردستاني لان يعني
لديه ال ال المناورات من عده همم يعني
عندك شهور ويحاول ان يقوم بعمليه
في الجنوب التركي ولكنها يعني بشكل بسيط
لكن هذه المره يعني العمليه هذه هي همم
لديها تداريات كثيره جدا على المستوى
الخارجي
القيادات الكبيره بالنسبه لكل الثاني او
لقصر او غيرهم همم
لم يتوقف الامر اكثر من ذلك لانه في
النهايه هذا عمل امني ليس عمل عسكري يتضح
معالمه بشكل مباشر وطبعا اذا خربنا هذا
حزب الله الثاني مثلا لكن اذا كانت داعش
خلف هذه العمليه مثلا همم ينكرت يمكن
يعني القاء القبض على الكثير من عناصر
داعش داخل اسطنبول نفسها فهل فهذه العمليه
يعني يجب ان نفكر هذه الطريقه ربما
لانقاء القبض على عناصر
اسطنبول همم
لكن يعني نحن سننتظر ال همم التحقيقات من
قبل
الداخليه وايضا افراغ المنطقه يعني هذا
ايضا يجب ان نذكره يعني الناس
افراخوا خلال يعني خلال ساعه من الزمان
لانه يعني القوات الامن والاستخبارات
التركيه قالت انه في احتمال انفجار ثاني
هذا يعني انه كان لديها معلومات بشكل او
باخر عن وجود شيء ما همم هذا الذي حدث
فرضيه العمل ايه همم الارهابي وهنا مثل ما
قالته انه منطقه امنيه همم بامتياز محصنه
امنيه ولكن جرى فيها الخرق
نعم يعني انا اضيف على ذلك يعني في نهايه
هذا الشارع توجد القنصليه السوريه
اليونانيه والروسيه يعني نحن نتكلم عن همم
مهم جدا همم لذلك يعني انا
البحث عن الخلل كيفيه الخلل هذا الذي حصل
في حال فرضنا فرضيه العمل الارهابي يعني
بدايه البحث عن هذا الخلل والا همم يعني
المكان يعني هذا المكان يعني ربما من اهم
المناطق في في اسطنبول في هذا السياق يعني
لذلك تنظيم اذا كان عمل ارهابي اذا هناك
تنظيم يعني محترف في نقول في هذا ال- اا
في هذا العمل او في هذا التغيير
كان امين
همم
يعني سننتظر
حتى الانواع يعني تصريحه قال في الساعه
الرابعه عشر دقائق كان هذا الانفجار بعدد
القتل الجرحى في تصاعد واضح القتلى
موجودون لكن لم يصلح من اسم من نصيحه
الجنسيات لعبا قد يكون كله متراك او غير
اتراك ايضا همم عدم اعطاء معلومات يوضح ان
هناك همم متابعه لموضوع ما لكن انا اظن
انه ايضا همم يعني عنصر الصدمه يعني
الناس هنا في تركيا موجوده هل هو عنصر
سيكون الاخرين لا اعلم حقيقه لكن همم
الموضوع حقيقه صعب تجاوزه
بمجرد همم يعني نقول فقط تصريحات او
اعلانات لان هناك رسائل واضحه وقصيره جدا
في هذا التفجير في هذا الزمان وفي هذا
المكان
اللي عم يشوفوا الان واياك على الشاشه حجم
القوه الامنيه الشرطه ومكافحه الارهاب لا
يعني في وحدات همم بالمئات همم في الشارع
يعني هذا يحبث فرضيه انه من يحادث عربي
همم بعدين حجم السيارات الامنيه ناقلات
الجند سيارات الاسعاف يؤكد ان شيئا كبيرا
ما حصل طيب في سؤال سؤال مباشر تاثير هذا
على المشهد السياسي الداخلي التركي كيف
يمكن ان يؤثر هذا الانفجار في حال تاكدت
فرضيه العمل الارهابي على المشهد السياسي
الداخلي التركي
قبل ان اسالك تاثير عن القطاع السياحي
لانه هذه المنطقه السياحيه بامتياز يعني
اهم نقطه سياحيه ربما في اسطنبول
يعني تاثيرها على كل اسطنبول حتى لو كان
اسطنبول مدينه كبيره جدا يعني لكن مجرد
تفجير واحد مثل هذا وان كان صغير
[موسيقى]
يجعل الامور فوقها داخلها كما يقال حتى
انا اذكر يعني عندك مرات تكلمت على شاشه
واحده في داخل اسطنبول فانه سيعتبر هذا
النجاح كبير له لان هذه العمليه ستعطي
ابعاد كثيره جدا اللي همم
تتداعيات السلبيه التي ستتهالى في هذه
العمليه يعني مثلا سياحيه مثلا الامنيه
الجدار السياسي القادم الان بين الاحزاب
السياسيه في الداخل التركي بين الاختلاف
الحاكم بين الانطلاق المعارضه لان الان
سيتم اللون على وزاره الداخليه التي تحت
قياده الاختلاف الحاكم واا هل هناك تراجع
همم يجب زياده الاجراءات الامنيه خصوصا
نحن في ابواب عطله
يعني التغيرات كثيره في هذا الاسبوع
القادم يعني همم
الموضوع كبير في هذا السياق خلوها يعني من
اجل يعني اظهار ان الامن التركي ما زال
عنده ثغرات ممكن تجاوزها وهذا لديه دلالات
اخرى يعني خارج تركيا ايضا يعني اظن ان
الرساله
ليست سهله يعني واضح ان ابعاد هذا العمل
يطال كل شيء متعلق فيه في تركيا
وزير الداخليه وغيره وحتى على اللواء ان
يخرج بعد فتره اظن يلقي خطاب يشرح على
الاقل ما حصل في هذا همم
يعني احنا نتكلم على يعني مساله عابره
حقيقتين الموضوع كثير في ذلك ال ال كما
تفضل يعني تواجد الامني الكثير واضح ان
هناك همم يعني اما خرج لي شيء ثاني او انه
اجراء روتيني ولكن يعني يجب ان نضع كل
الاحتمالات اذا كان هناك قنبله ثانيه او
عنصر ثاني ارهابي بذلك لا يوجد تصريحات هل
هناك معلومات يعني لا تظهر على الشاشه من
اجل متابعه
الملاحقات الامنيه يعني هي هي نظريات يعني
فقط نقولها لان واضح ان هناك همم
مصمت حتى الان صامت حكومي واضح فهو
احتمالين اما انا ليست معلومات متوفره
بشكل كامل هذا او انهم ملاحقه ل- همم يعني
عناصر الامنيه مثلا لا يتم الابلاغ عن هذا
الشيء بس فراس بانتظار يعني مزيد من
المعلومات التي هي صحيحه حتى الساعه همم
لنعرف كيف سنتلمس يعني همم قراءه همم
مضامين همم هذا الحدث قبل ان اسالك بشكل
مفصل ايضا عن تاثير ذلك على القطاع
السياحي
وان تركيا تعتمد على السياحه
كرافد الاقتصادها والاقتصاد التركي يعاني
كما غير من الاقتصادات في هذه المرحله في
سؤال من احد المتابعين على تويتر يسالك هل
يمكن الربط همم بين هذا الانفجار
والتطورات في المشهد السياسي السوري
تحديدا حديث عن تطبيع تركي مع الحكومه
السوريه هذا من احد المتابعين ما رايه
يعني رساله ما بهذا الاتجاه
الحقيقه
بهذا الشكل لكن اذا مرتبطه بالملف السوري
التي لديها ارتباط
الثاني هل همم يعني الامور خاصه بها او
شيء من هذا القبيل ممكن في هذا همم التطور
يعني ممكن نضعها في هذا لكن يعني سنعود
وكاننا نعود كردستان يعني اذا كان مرتبط
في الملف السوري همم ليس اظن لديها من
القدره الا عن طريق العمال كردستاني
لديها ضعف بشكل كبير حتى داعش يعني
كثيره جدا داخل التركي حتى لم يقعد يعني
فيها ارقام كثيره
في عندك عمليات وين بعضها فشل لكن نجح
بالوصول على الاقل بعضها استطاع ان يصل
الى هدفه والاطلاق النار في في مرسين مثلا
بعضها لم يستطيع الوصول تم اللقاء القبض
عليها مسبقه حتى صرحت الداخليه بيننا
اوقفت اكثر من علماء اكثر 44 عمليه
ارهابيه يعني حسبي الله يذكر لكن في هذا
السياق ممكن في هذا السياق لكن بعد اخرى
انا يعني لا اتوقع يعني طيب استاذ فراس
ارجو ان تبقى معي ساعود اليك بعد قليل
دعني اسرك المحلل السياسي من اسطنبول
السيد جواد اهلا وسهلا بك همم
نتساقط المعلومات واياك ولكن في ظل الشح
المعلومات حتى الساعه اي قراءه يمكن ان
تعطيها لهذا الانفجار واي فرضيه تراها
الاقرب الى الواقع بدايه
طبعا يعني هناك صمت حكومي لوسائل الاعلام
التركي داخليا الان بدها قبل دقائق
ام بسبب الخلل الامني وشارع استقلال الان
اغلقوها من كل الجوانب بسبب وقوع
اعماله الارهابيه محتمله مره اخرى لكن
بشكل عام
قته في وسائل الاعلام والذي بدر الى
اذان انه بصراحه قبل كل الانتخابات
في السنين الماضيه خاصه سنه 2015
وقعت تفجيرات قويه جدا
واعمال الارهابيه في المدن المختلفه في
تركيا
والشارع التركي صوتوا لصالح حكومه بسبب
خلل الامني وبسبب المخابز
ثروته لصالح الحكومه وهم فازوا في
الانتخابات السابقه الان يبادر الى الاذان
انه هل تتكرر نفس السيناريوهات مره اخرى
النتيجه كانت هناك تدابير جيده جدا
للحكومه التركيه ووزاره الداخليه ولم نسمع
باي خبر من التفجيرات في السنين الاخيره
لكن الان مع وقوع هذا الحدث اتهامات
الموجهه الى الحكومه الان صارت
ملموش بمعنى انه
البلد صار كم ايام
من البلد
ساره مخيم مثلا ارى اكثر من اربع ملايين
من السوريين اكثر من مليون عراقي وايضا
ايراني
وعفغانيون ومن بلاد الافارقه وغير ذلك
قريب واكثر من 10 مليون من اللاجئين الان
في تركيا
بسبب السياسات الخارجيه الخاطئه الان مع
الاسف الشديد يعني خلايا ناعمه لداعش كانت
متهمه واكثر تواجدا في تركيا كما كانت
هناك احصائيات وارقام التي نشرها مؤسسات
المدنيه الغربيه في تركيا وغير ذلك ولهذا
السبب الحكومه والوزاره الداخليه خاصه
طبعا كانوا يتخذون تدابير شديده لكن
بصراحه يعني بسبب
تسرب الارهابيين عبر اللاجئين كانت مقتمله
وهذا وقع بصراحه
الان ااا معلم الخوف بدا يسيطر على على
مواطنين بصراحه نحكمواطنين لم نكن نذهب
الى شارع الاستقلال شارع الشهير جدا بسبب
كثره الازدحام وان كنا نرى انه ممكن اي
لحظه تقع احداث هنا ولا هذا السبب مع
الاسف ليس فقط شرسه استقلال هناك محل
مناطق مختلفه في مدينه اسطنبول
هناك خلل الامن موجود هناك لاجئين غير
شرعيين موجود عندما تقوم القوات الامنيه
باعتقال اللاجئين الغير الشرعيه كانوا
يقومون باعتقال الاف من اللاجئين الاجانب
وعلى هذا السبب كانت الامر كان الامر
واضحا جدا
لاسمع راي الاستاذ فراس حول ما قلته سيد
جواد ما رايك بما قاله السيد جواد السفراس
يعني سياسات الحكوميه تتحمل المسؤوليه
تحديدا موضوع اللاجئين
يعني اذا احتمال تسرب ارهابيين عبر عشرات
الالعاب لبالمئات الاف ملايين اللاجئين
ربما الموجودين على الاراضي التركيه هذا
والكلام للسيد جواد ما رايه
يعني هذا ما تكلمنا فيه قبل قليل الجدل
السياسي الذي سيحصل في تركيا
وبسبب طبعا
الداخليه الان بقياده الاختلاف الحاكم
الحكومه ولذلك هي المسؤوله امام المجتمع
التركي في اي خلل ذلك كل هذه الفرضيات
توضع امام همم الحكومه تطولها امام
البرلمان
سياسيا سيتم فيها همم
الحرب السياسيه القادمه بين الاطراف
يعني في الامس كان يتكلم عن همم الاختلاف
يعني بسبب عفوا التعاون الامن التعاون
الامني بين تركيا ودواء المنظمه التعاون
التركي وغيرها بسبب هذا الامر لذلك يعني
كل شيء ورد لكن انا اظن ان البدايه هو
البحث عن خلل الذي اوصل الى هذا
التفجير ولذلك الانفجار الذي حصل الان
يعني نقدر انه سيمر بسهوله وهذا ما تفضلت
فيقا وقليل تداعياته على المشهد السياسي
الداخلي في تركيا
الاستاذ جواد ايضا يعني اشار الى موضوع
انه في صمت وتعتيم همم حتى الساعه من
الحكومه التركيه من همم
السلطات الامنيه من الشرطه حول ما يجري
همم وكانه وصفوا بالمريب هل تعتقد ان هذا
التعتيم او الصمت عن خلفيات
وملابسات هذا الانفجار مقصوده
ولماذا
يعني انا كما قلت قبل قليل هي يعني فيها
احتمالين الاحتمال الاول هو اما عدم توفر
المعلومات
لان
اي تصريح خاطئه من الان بعد هذا العمل
الذي يعني اركب ضربه المشهد السياسي
المشهد انني المشهد السياحي المشهد التركي
الذي ذلك
[موسيقى]
صعب سيتم المسائل عليه بشكل كبير وكبير
جدا لكن
سننتظر سننتظر يعني
تصريحات الداخليه يعني فقط كانت تصريح
مقتضب جدا بالنسبه للوالد لم يعلن عن اي
شيء عن تحليل التوقيت الانفجار وان هناك
جرحى وقتله طيب
جواد سيد
جواد قال ان التفجير في الزمان والمكان
مدروس جدا يعني من الجهه التي قامت بهذا
التوجيه نعود فانذكر نحن لا نتبنى اي
نظريه او اي فرضيه ولكن يعني الفرضيه
الاكثر ترجيحا حتى الساعه نتيجه ما ما ما
نشاهد همم والحيثيات المتوفره لدينا تحبب
فرضيه العمل الارهابي همم في حال كان جواب
يعني همم داعش او عناصر مرتبطه بداعش وراء
هذا التفجير في حال اي رد للحكومه التركيه
ترى طيب وفي حال كان عناصر لحزب العمال او
مرتبطه بحزب العمال وراء هذه الانفجارات
اي رد ايضا
طبعا بالنتيجه اذا كان هناك
اذا كان هناك ما قاموا من قبل حزب العمال
الكردستاني الارهابي
الحكومه سوف تقوم باعتقال
مشبوهين بهم في اسطنبول بالنتيجه اوكار
لهم في مناطق مختلفه في اطراف اسطنبول
موجوده وايضا سوف يقومون بالتشديد
العمليات العسكريه في شمال سوريا وشمالي
العراق هذا الامر كان سابقا موجوده لكن
بالنسبه الى دواعش انا اظن انه الحكومه
اذا ارادت ارادت ان تعتقل وتسيطر على
مجموعات الارهابيه قادرين وزير الداخليه
كان يقول مثلا
بحدود اقل من 100 شخص
التحقوا الى حزب العمال الكردستاني وصعد
الى جبال القنديل وغير ذلك يعني كانوا
يعتزون انه نحن انهينا الارهاب
والارهابيين ونحن قمنا بابي انجح وزير
الداخليه في تاريخ تركيا وغير ذلك لكن نحن
نعرف انه الخلل كان محتملا جدا اذا كانوا
دواعش طبعا ايضا سوف يقومون
بتفتيش الاكثر وتدابير الاكثر
يعني
[موسيقى]
سوف يقوم ومن قام
بحمله لصالح داعش وغير ذلك او بالنسبه الى
راديكالين في تركيا لكن بشكل عام السياسه
الحكوميه التركيه الخارجيه بالنسبه الى
سوريا كانت خاطئه بالنسبه الان مثلا
الحدود الايرانيه التركيه مفتوحه جدا
وعشرات
الافغانيين بل مئات والالاف
ياتون عبر الحدود الايرانيه همم يعني بشكل
غير شرعي
ويدخلون مجموعات يعني ياتون بالباصات
ويطلقون ليطلقونه في شوارع اسطنبول وغير
ذلك هذه الصور والفيديوهات موجوده ومنتشره
في وسائل الاعلام التركي الحكومه لحد الان
لم تتخذ تدابير بالنسبه الى تسرب اللاجئين
من الحدود الايرانيه التركيه وعشرات
الالات من الافغانيين جاءوا الى تركيا عبر
الحدود الايرانيه ولا يوجد اي تعاون بين
الحكومه وبين ايران مع الاسف الشديد هذه
القضايا موجوده مهما تقومون
باخراجها اولاهم
يعودون بسرعه يعودون سوف يعود الى البلد
مره اخرى ولهذا السبب عليهم
الان ااا لم نسمع اي تصريحات ايجابيه او
تصريحات بالنسبه الى هذا الحدث الاخير
ونتوقع بصراحه احداث اخرى بسبب الاحتمال
الخلل الامني في تركيا طيب في سؤال وجهتم
منذ قليل السيد فراس وجهه لك ايضا وهو
ساله احد المتابعين على تويتر هل يمكن
الرابط بين هذا الانفجار اليوم والتطورات
السياسيه في المشهد السوري تحديدا يعني
حسب يقصد
تطبيع تركي محتمل مع الحكومه السوريه
بتعرف في الاول الاخيره جرى الحديث عن
اتصالات وعن امكانيات تطبيق سوريا هل يمكن
الرابط بين ذلك ان هذه الرساله باتجاهات
معينه الى الحكومه السوريه
طبعا الحكومه التركيه لحد الان جاءوا
بتصريحات ايجابيه لكن لم نسمع ولم نراي
خطوات عمليه في طريقه طبعا يقولون نحن كم
مجموعات استخباراتيه قمنا بالاتصالات الان
وصل دور
الدبلوماسيه علاقات الدبلوماسيه لكن فقط
قبل قبل
تكمل بس
الخبر العاجل الحاكم اسطنبول يؤكد الان
اربعه قتل حتى الساعه وثمانيه وثلاثون
جرحا في انفجار منطقه تقسيم اذا حتى الان
والكلام لحاكم اسطنبول الذي يؤكد وجود
اربعه قتله و 38 جرحا في انفجار منطقه
تقسيم في اسطنبول
نعم بارك الله في قناتكم الكريمه في نفس
اللحظه في شاشات التركيه وانتم تنشرون
الخبر
اللاجئين السوريين ممكن سوف يكون راضيين
عن تطبيقات النتيجه
لعوده اللاجئين لكن
[موسيقى]
القوميين المتطرفين في تركيا
هم يتهمون الحكومه بشده والقوميه ساره
متطرفه جدا في تركيا مع الاسد الشديد
هؤلاء الان يقولون الحقوا معنا في توجيه
الاتهامات الى الحكومه التركيه وعلى
السوريين ان يرجعون جميعهم وترحيل
بالاشجار الى بلدهم وانا اخاف من التوتر
بين الشعب التركي واللاجئين بسبب تحرير
المعارضه المتطرفه في تركيا
فراسيه فراس يعني كلام مهم عم بيقوله
استاذ جواد انه من التداعيات المحتمله ان
يستغل القوميون الاتراك هذا الانفجار
لشنحمله ضغط على الحكومه من اجل طرد
اللاجئين تحديدا اللاجئين السوريين
ما رايك
مع الاستاذ
[موسيقى]
يبقى اي حاجه ما يحصل في تركيا يستفيد منه
اي سياسي وفي هذه القضيه ولذلك انا
لذلك همم تذكر يعني كما كنا في البدايه ان
هذا الانفجار يفتح تداعيات كثير جدا على
الصعيد التركي وتداعيات اخرى ونضعها في
الخامس
السياحه وغيرها وهذه الامور ولكن على
الصعيد الداخلي في هذا التوقيت
ونحن يعني الانتخابات التركيه ليست بعيده
عن همم يعني عن الصناديق في الشهور
القادمه كل شيء وارد هناك حقيقه سيكون
الحرب سياسي داخل الموضوع اللاجئين
الموضوع الذي قدوم الكبير ليس فقط
للسوريين ان احنا نتكلم عن يعني ملايين من
اللاجئين همم ومختلف من الاماكن من ايران
يعني ايقاع هناك اكثر من مليون شخص جاء من
افغانستان عذاب اكثر تصريح الداخليه
يتكلمون عن 600000 افغاني من من الهند من
مناطق متعدده وحتى انا تركي اصبحت كم مره
عبور او ردها لذلك انا اظن انه يعني
الوضع في الانمي في تركيا يحتاج الى اعاده
ترتيب واعاده سياق تعاون امني ربما مع
كافه الدول المنطقه يعني هذه مشكله خصوصا
ان هناك يعني
العمل
الدكتور سمير حول
اللسانيون المشددين وان كان يعني تقريبا
انتهى نوعا ما ولكن كل فرضيات الحقيقه
والده في هذا السياق وهذا اظن انه يعني
هذا التغيير
يعني في سبب مشاكل امنيه
للحكومه التركيه او حتى لوزاره الداخليه
على الاقل اعود همم
اكده منذ قليل حاكم اسطنبول وجود اربعه
قتله حتى الساعه و 38 جريحا في انفجار
منطقه تقسيم في اسطنبول هذه المنطقه همم
السياحيه والمنطقه الهامه جدا التي دائما
تغص بالمره بالسياح وهنالك اكثر من همم
همم سفاره واا
موقع لمنظمات دوليه في هذا همم الشارع
السؤال ايضا من احد المتابعين استسوارات
يقول لك ايا تكون خلفيات الانفجار هل يشكل
هذا الانفجار صفعه امنيه للحكومه التركيه
وصفحه سياسيه للحزب الحاكم ام لا يمكن قول
ذلك
نعم انا اضعها في هذا السياره يعني هذا
العمل الذي حصل في ايباد نحن نفرده
افترضيه العمل الارهابي نعم يعني هي صفحه
قويه في قلب العاصمه في عفوا في قلب
العاصمه السياحيه الى اسطنبول وهي عاصمه
الاقتصاديه وفي هذا الشارع تحديدا في
القنصليات وفي ايضا يعني هو له يعني معنى
كبير معنى الجمهوري ومعنى كثير سياحي
يعني انا اظن طبعا يعني هذا ممكن اعتباره
في هذا السياق صحيح
ايضا ايا تكون خلفيات هذا الانفجار كما
يقول هذا المتابع هل يشكل صفحه امنيه
للحكومه التركيه والاهم صفعا سياسيه للحزب
الحاكم على ابواب الانتخابات ام لا يعني
يمكن للحزب الحاكم بشكل او باخر ااه يعني
استغلال مثل هكذا احداث
لو استمرت التفسيرات اييه لا سمح الله عده
مرات نعم هذا سوف تكون لصالح الحكومه
التركيه يعني بسبب يعني تجاربنا السابقه
تشير انه الشعب التركي من الخوف في الخلل
الامني سوف يعودون تثبيتهم للحكومه
التركيه مره اخرى لكن اذا كانت تفسير
تفسير منفرد بهذا الشكل نعم هذا سوف
يستفيد المعارضه سوف تستفيد
واذا كانت هناك خلل عندي مستمر نعم
الحكومه سوف تاتي بالممانعه
لنشر الاخبار ولنشر ما يجري في تركيا سوف
تكون مشكله كبيره
وسيله جيده بيد الحكومه التركيه انه بسبب
خلل الامني نحن نقوم بتدابير حتى تدابير
اعلاميه السياسيه لكن اذا وقع هذا التفس
انتهى هذا سوف تكون وسيله بيد المعارضه
خاصه حزب الظهر المتطرف الذي يعني دائما
يحرض الشعب التركي لاخراج السوريين من
تركيا
[موسيقى]
سؤال ايضا ولكن في ناحيه اخرى يعني عن
تداعيات هذا الانفجار نحن نعرف كما ذكر
السيد فراس انه هذا الشارع يشكل شريان
اقتصادي
وتجاري وسياح هام يعني في قلب العاصمه
الاقتصاديه لتركيا اسطنبول نحن نعرف ان
العاصمه السياسيه هي انقره اي تداعيات
سيتركها مثل هكذا انفجار على انقطاع
السياحي تحديدا والتي تعتمد يعني تركي على
السياحه كرافد اساسي الاقتصاديا ونحن نعرف
عن الاقتصاد التركي يعاني مؤخرا
طبعا مع الاساس وقع هذا التفسير في مكان
استراتيجي مهم جدا سياحيه
وطبعا الشعب التركي بشكل عام يرفضون
ويستنكرون هذا التبشير لكن
هل السياح الاجانب سوف
يتاثرون سلبيا طبعا من مثل هذه الاحداث
يعني اذا كان اي في اي بلد ولهذا السبب
الحكومه التركيه لو تتكرر هذه تفجيرات في
عده المدن لا سامح الله او مدينه اسطنبول
نعم هذا سوف تكون تاثيره سلبيا جدا بانه
تركيا بلد سياحي مثلا هذا العام اكثر من
40 مليون
تركيا بشكل عام لكن اذا كانت تفجيرات
مستمره نعم هذا سوف يكون تاثيرها سلبيا
جدا
ولخروج همم السياح الاجانب من تركيا بشكل
سريع لكن نتمنى ان تاخذ حكومه جناحكم ت
جيده بشهاده نعم استاذ فراس طيب في
مستغربه يعني وانا يعني من تابع التغطيه
انا واياك انا اتصفح المواقع تحديدا همم
الرسميه التركيه يعني حتى الساعه لم يخرج
اي مسؤول همم ليتوجه الى الشعب التركي الى
الوسائل الاعلام التركيه للحديث عن ما
يجري على الاقل يعطي معلومات يعني ليقطع
الشك باليقين مما يجري يعني سوء ما قاله
حاكم اسطنبول همم
بتغريده انه في اربعه قتله و38 جريحه في
انفجار منطقه تقسيم لا وجود لاي تصريحات
رسميه او خرج مثلا وزير الداخليه او مسؤول
مثلا الشرطه في اسطنبول وقام بمؤتمر صحفي
واعطى معلومات ده دلالات يعني نستطيع من
خلالها ان نتلمس ما يجري ليس هذا مستغربا
انه حتى الساعه لم يخرج اي مسؤول
يكون الخروج بعد فتره لكن حتى الان هذا
الخروج انا اظن بسبب ااا
اذا نقل عن يعني الصدمه من الخبر نفسه او
الصدمه لنتيجه انفجار وهذا يعني اقرب الى
المنطق طبعا معه ولكن اذا قلنا هذا الشيء
اللي قصدنا اي ان هناك عدم تيقز امني وهذه
نقطه اخرى خلافيه ستفتح الباب على
صراعيه للمسائله الداخليه التركيه همم انا
اظن في هذا السياق يعني ربما هذا الصم كان
همم يعني حتى الان يعني لم تعطي اي
معلومات هل هناك ملاحقات
حقيقه متعدده اما الاستاذ
لعدم اعطاء معلومات او ملاحقات امنيه او
شيء في هذا السياق همم المع
يعني بشكل عام بتركيا دائما ال- المسؤولون
طبعا يخرجون مباشره في اي حادث يحصل همم
في تركيا في اي حاجه ثانيه يحصل هناك سواء
ارهابيا او طبيعيا يعني يكون هناك الخروج
مباشره لكن هذا الحدث انا اظن انه يعني
لانه حدث كبير حقيقه كبير وهذا اظن همم
يجعلني في في
الخروجات وليست تصريحات لا نريد تصريحات
نريد
مراسل العربيه يؤكد الان همم لان مراسل
العربيه انا في جار اسطنبول نجم عن قنبله
قنبله وضعت داخل حقيبه بمعنى انه من محدث
عربي هذا قنبله وضعت داخل حقيبه اي تعليق
نعم صحيح هذا ما فرضناهم في البدايه يعني
نوعيه هذا التسجيل وال يعني من التفجيرات
السابقه او الخبرات السابقه يعني
هذا كان المحتمل الاكثر
ويعني هذه الطريقه واظن ان ينتمي الى حزب
الله